going to treat you God I said Trisha you
know you were there on Good Morning
Britain on the day the uh well the
morning after the Oprah Winfrey
interview air we had a pretty Lively
series of exchanges on that show as you
know I left Good Morning Britain the
next day because I uh was asked to
apologize for disbelieving her claims of
racism I said I wanted to see evidence
of this so-called racism we now learned
from Harry's own mouth that they did not
call the royal family races after all so
I'm not quite sure why I had to leave my
job are you
yes
um because they actually didn't use the
words racist oh please and
would you like me to finish no I tell
you what I want to do Trisha before you
go any further I want to play you what
they said on Oprah then you can repeat
what you've just said let's watch this
and also concerns and conversations
about how dark his skin might be when
he's born
what about
how dark your baby is going to be
potentially and what that would mean or
look like what was that conversation
that conversation I'm never going to
share
um but at the time
the time it was awkward I was a bit
shocked
yeah and the end of that first clip of
Meghan Markle goes on to say that if the
baby was too dark that would be a
problem yes you may think that so that
I'm afraid that is racism
the charge was racism against the royal
family at the time they produced no
evidence her version of events was
nearly two years after Harry's timeline
when this happened they've never named
The Royal member who said this stuff and
now we get told casually it's not racism
all right can you just play that again
because there must be something wrong at
my line I didn't hear either Harry or
Megan use the word racism I heard you
use it I saw the Press use it I didn't
actually hear them use the word and
that's what when we had that a robust
exchange of of words I think what I said
to you is that I do get fed up with
other people labeling white people
labeling what is and isn't racist to to
black people now if they'd actually use
the word racism
honestly this is utterly ridiculous so
what is racism I'll tell you what racism
is I'll tell you what racism is
let me get uncomfortable I know I'm
white Morgan's about to lecture a black
woman about racism
I'm about to give you an example of
racism as a middle-aged white man who I
know is right the enemy because you know
let me tell you one example is an
example of racism would be somebody
expressing concern about the skin color
of a baby from a mixed race marriage and
when the when the interviewer then says
what if it was darker that would be a
problem yes you may think that that is
an example of somebody expressing racism
and that became the headline and
narrative for the next two years after
the interview and for you to shamelessly
sit there and pretend that wasn't what
they meant is utter bilge if there were
more black people in the media in the
you know in the Tabloid media they may
have had the opportunity to look into
that and explain it a little bit more I
didn't see it as racism I saw it and
that's why I got crossed when you you
decided to label it later I didn't
decide to do anything I well in that in
when we were having they literally
confirmed Oprah Winfrey but a member
attempts to talk about this in other
than headline news when I'm trying to
have a recent conversation I get shouted
over why is my experience or what black
people experience why do we have no
currency why am I not allowed they've
literally had front pages about the
racist royal family for two years how
much more does Meghan Markle one has no
one has called the the royal family
racist I mean I I forgot
I would say it's built on built on the
Commonwealth and we already know Charles
has had problems you know they've talked
about the crown that Camilla may or may
not use because the the history of one
of the Diamonds the Chloe nor diamonds
and what have you we know that the
royalty and many royal families around
the world were built on the backs of
slavery racism commonwealth countries
having good stolen or or taken away from
we know that unfortunately it's not
taught in school sorry
the history is racism
without me jumping in sorry great
respect to you you can't just keep
talking I'm allowed to ask questions
it's an interview right my question for
you is you're not allowed to make
statements right without listening to
what somebody says Meghan Markle made a
direct charge supported by her husband
that a member for the royal family had
expressed concern about the potential
skin color of their baby which if it was
too dark would be a problem that is
racism they made a charge yes that's
called racism yeah if you think that if
a baby's too dark it's a problem that's
called racism sorry to have to lecture
you about racism and I'm not allowed to
as a white man but actually that is an
example of racism
tell us about my history tell us about
the history of black people and what
rate what's that got to do with what
they said
because they didn't say it was racist
yes they did somebody else used that
word they stepped aside from using that
word I think very deliberately why did
they win an award tell us about
unconsciously why do they tell us about
unconscious bias I'll tell you about
unconscious delusion which is they won
an awards what does it mean I do the
questions you do the answering it's
called an interview show right it's
before Christmas they accepted an award
for their heroic heroic stand against
the structural racism of this royal
family based on what they told Oprah
Winfrey that was all a complete lie
there was no racism we now know they
never meant to say it was racism you're
supporting them that was never meant to
be racism queering the color of a baby
from a mixed race marriage and
expressing concern if it was going to be
too dark it's not racism Trish you take
me for a complete mug it couldn't be a
clearer example of racism why deny it
really yeah no
so so am I right in thinking that you
know better than you you I have no idea
of what racism is I didn't say that I
didn't say that I said to you very
clearly I'm sorry that you you sorry
what do you keep doing you keep putting
words into my mouth I'm not actually
saying and the viewers aren't stupid
well that's they can hear the
conversation with them they didn't use
you want people to believe that actually
what she said Meghan Markle to Oprah
Winfrey supported by Harry does not
constitute racism and I'm afraid no I
said it's unconscious but I think you
are being deliberately either delusional
or disingenuous which one is it
you haven't explained what you
understand by unconscious bias so I'm
not quite sure you're not doing the
interview ah no I don't care sorry we've
now moved from racism to unconscious
bias right I would like to move to
unconscious or conscious delusion
because we all know what she said to
Oprah Winfrey we all know that for the
last two years the royal family has been
reeling from the charge of being racist
because one of their senior members
expressed concern over the skin color of
their unborn baby and now we get told
casually by Harry clearly feeling a bit
of remorse about what's gone down here
because I read the whole book today this
story doesn't appear in the book this
allegation of racism isn't in there why
where is it gone why nor is he nor is
the allegation where Meghan Mark which
is the other thing I queried at the time
before I had to leave the building I
also said where is the proof that she
went to somebody at Buckingham Palace
about her suicidal thoughts and was told
she couldn't get help that's not in the
book either where's that gone and by the
way what happened to him at the same
time when his brother allegedly attacked
him he called his therapist who was on
speed dial why couldn't he do that for
his wife anyway these are ponderous
questions for you to think about
treasure I want to come back after the
break